Live Captions by:
@smiley845 with @whitecoatcapxg
>> Hello everyone. This
morning, we're going to open up
with another
React talk from Sarrah
Vesselov.  She serves as a
director at women who code.
Let's hear it from Sarrah.
[ Applause ]
>> SARRAH: So I had some
snafus with fonts and notes.
But thank you for coming this
early.  As you can probably tell
from the title
of my talk, it's based on
painful personal experience, and
I wanted to start today by
sharing that experience with
you.  So in 2015, I worked in a
small Tampa start-up as a senior
UI developer.  My main role was
to build scalable, maintainable
CSS
architectures.  We worked for
months on a vapor concept.
There was a lot of buzz, and we
snagged our first client.  So it
was time to get down to business
and begin writing production
quality code.  There was an
build exciting opportunity to it
out from scratch, and we decided
we were going to do it in React.
Just one problem.  There were
not any best practices for
styling in React at that time.
And this is where the Strubel
trouble started for me.
My ten plus years of styling
applications meant nothing.  It
meant that I was a dinosaur.  In
2014, My ten plus years an
engineer at Facebook gave a talk
that changed everything.  His
talk was putting CSS in your JS.
And this really represented a
shift from traditional
architectures to more
component-based ark tech
techture.  So the next few
months, honestly, were some of
the worst in my career.  Every
presentation, every conversation
became a confrontation.  It was
meant to shame and bully one
side or the other into seeing
the error of their ways.  By the
end of it all, none of us were
friends anymore.  If this sounds
crazy? It was.  If it sounds
familiar, I'm really
sorry.  But it didn't have to
end this way.
The team imploded not because of
bad technology choices.  Most of
what we tried would have worked
if we stuck with it.  The
problem was Us and the way we
approached the problem.  We made
things far more complicated and
personal than they needed to be.
If we had been asking the right
questions instead of avoiding
each other, we could have
avoided the whole mess.  It was
two years ago.  A lot has
changed, but the debate has not.
This is a recent Google search I
did just for
CSS.  I want to talk about
that today.
So let's look at both sides
of the debate.  We all know that
CSS is
broken right? CSS dependencies
make style collision and
overriding inevitable.  Looking
at separation of concerns all
along on the CSS side.  We look
at separation of concerns as a
separation of technologies.  And
in CSS and JS, it's really a
separation of components and
what each piece is doing.  And
then the cascade causes
thousands of lines of dead code
and doesn't work with CSS
at scale.  There are equally
strong gripes against CSS and
JSS.  CSS
isn't broken.  Why are we
cascade is your friend if you
know how to use it, and of
course, inline styles are
inventing the hackable.  So both
styles have some pretty serious
concerns about what the other
side
is doing.  So now that we've
heard the two sides, let's look
at the
options.
wheel.
Live Captions by:
@smiley845 with @whitecoatcapxg.
The
has a class.
Elements should never be
directly styled.  No nesting of
styles.  Choose clear naming
conventions.  So in this
example, I have my friend
component.  Friend is a block, a
stand-alone entity that has its
own meaning and identity.  Any
friend is an element of that
block.  They are tied to that
block and have no meaning on
their own.  And modifier is just
an extra class name to change
appearance or behavior.
Modifier should only modify the
their own.  And modifierblock,
never replace it.  In terms of
component structure, here's a
simple component structure to
start with.  I'm by no means
telling you this is the way to
do it, it's just one way to do
it.  I think it's very
personalized from project to
project.  Here we've got a
they are stateless and they
simply takesimple  props.  They
make API calls, etc., etc.
There's a lot of benefits to
this approach.  You get better,
but different type of separation
concerns, and you get
reusability in other projects,
if that's something you're
concerned with.  The
presentation components can be
worked on by the design team,
without concern that it will
affect the app's The
componentsusing  We're straight
C NothingSS.  to
configure or  put together.
Using BIM and presentational
components, each component can
be used over and over again in
other projects.  It is
impossible as long as everyone
is following that syntax.  So
the less there is to evaluate,
the faster it's going to render.
And I think that BIM structure
lends itself perfectly to
linting so you can make sure
that every structure added
conforms to the same standards.
But there are some cons.  Let's
face it.  Naming things is
really hard.  It's probably one
of the hardest things we do.  It
sounds crazy to anyone who
doesn't do this for a living,
but most of my time has been
spent figuring out what to name
something so someone else knows
what I'm talking about.  The
rigid structure of BIM is what
makes it work and also what
makes it difficult to write
it first.  It can be frustrate
to being do something you can do
faster in another way, but
you're being forced into this
syntax and this particular
method.  So you've got to get
team buy-in in order for this
system to work.  And losing the
benefit of the cascade can be
seen as a pro or con, depending
on which side of the debate you
fall on.  The cascade can keep
things dry or result in
a bloated code base.
It's possible to use BIM for
theming, but I would say there
are far better methods out
there, say maybe something
that's important to you and the
work that you're doing.  And it
may not be a serious con, but
something around the underscores
and dashes feels really ugly.
Again, if it goes back to
writing something that's
difficult or doesn't come
naturally can make things a lot
slower.
So next I want to look at
pre-processors.  We're turning
this into that.  So CSS
preprocessor takes a language
and allows you to write dry code
faster.  Variables, operations,
mix-ins, you
name it.  I think sass is
probably one of the most well
known extension languages, and
that is what I will touch upon
in this talk.  So the bad news
about SASS is that you still
need to name things.  So in this
example, I'm continuing to use
the BEM naing component.
Nothing changes here.  The
component itself is set.  The
difference here is that instead
of having to write out each
class in its entirety, we're
nesting using the ampersand in
each class.  There's a lot of
ways I could dry this up
further.  Once compiled, the CSS
output is going to be exactly
the same as in the original
example.  And again, with the
folder structure, nothing is
really changed.  We're still
approaching each component as a
whole entity.  We're no longer
separating
HTML, HTML and CSS.
In this example, I actually have
the SASS outputting to an
individual CSS file that lives
within the component.  However,
you can do it a number of
different ways.  You can compile
this into one style sheet, and
load that whole style sheet
instead.
So pros.  What are pros to
preprocessors? SASS gives you
the power of variables, mix-ins,
nestings.  It's got a lot of
features that we have grown
dependent on.  You can dry up
your code quite a bit using
these features.  I also think a
lot of them are really easy to
pick up.  If you already know
CSS, there's no overhead to
jumping in and working with
SASS.  You can really do it
straight away without much help.
And similar to a first set-up,
each presentation component is
modular.  Each SASS file can be
loaded into one sheet.  So it
lends itself into working for
your team the way you need it
to.
There are some cons.  To use
SASS in your project, you'll
need to add dependencies.  It
isn't a big con considering what
we already do, but it's
something to keep in mind.  It's
just one more
layer.  Nesting can get out of
control very, very quickly.  I
have seen new devs nest
themselves straight to hell.
They're like ten deep, and they
can't figure out ohow that
happened.  So you have got to be
careful with SASS and nesting.
Having said that, I would argue
that the component composition
resists the needs of mix-in and
nesting.  They should be very,
very small.  They should be
very, very concentrated.  And
the amount of styling you need
should be relatively small.  So
you may not even need these
things.  And you have to name a
lot of things, right? We just
don't want to do
this.  It seems to be a really
popular refrain.  So I want to
talk about inline styles.
Inline styles are not the same
as CSS and JS, and I'm going to
get to that in a minute.  And
the first two methods I just
talked about have been the
standard for a long time.  I
think CSS inline goes back even
further.  But in 2015, the idea
of using them to style your
entire application seemed kind
of crazy.  Just like it sounds,
inline styles attach your styles
inline to the actual DOM node.
This is the same frame
component, so a simple example
of inline styles.  This is the
first example that the CSS and
JS folks brought to us in 2015.
And I got to say, we were
horrified when we saw this.
And to be fair, this is not how
most people are using inline
styles.  Most are using style
objects.  It's much more
maintainable than the first
example.  It's also the way
React handles Moin styling.
Most will place the styles in a
separate document and import
that into the component.  Sound
familiar? It should.  So, at the
time the thought for many of us
was seriously? You want us to
style an entire application like
this? The very thought of
styling an entire app by
injecting styles seemed
laughable at the time.  The big
argument, right, had been
working with CSS at scale.  From
the perspective of the CSS
folks, this was not scalable.
The font size, color palate of
the application had changed
several times since working on
the proof of concept.  How will
we manage monumental style
changes like that? Surely there
was a need for global
styles.
Even more at the time was
distressing it couldn't do.
learning whatInline
styles only supports a subset of
CSS.  CSS and JS allows you to
use all the power.  We're going
to get to those in a minute.  I
know I keep saying that, but
we're almost there.  While
inline styles are lacking quite
a bit, I think there are
positives to them.  Inline
styles forces you to change your
mental model and see each
component as its own entity.
This was something that it
really did for me.  I will admit
that I was not against the idea
of CSS and JS, but it did go
against everything that I had
learned in my years and years of
best practice, and it really put
my hackles up.  But sitting down
and writing a component and
using inline styles really
changed my view on that.  I was
able to see the component as its
own concern and see the value in
being able to localize those
styles.  And obviously, inline
styles are the trump card in
specificity, right? There's no
way someone's going to
accidentally override them or
leave unused styles hanging
around.  And if you intend to
stick with React long term, your
styles are still going to work,
it's going to be much easier to
move those over.  So the cons
list is a bit longer.
So, you'll need to depend on a
library to access basic CSS
features.  And this was one of
the big arguments from the CSS
side at the time.  We're just
adding all these things that CSS
does naturally.  Why would we do
this? And if you're not using a
library, it's necessary to
program JS work-arounds to
address queries, pseudo
selectors, all of the things
that CSS gives you just out of
the box.  And again, depending
on which side of the debate
you're on, you lose the cascade.
So you're not able to make
mobile style changes using the
cascade.  Every component would
need to be touched if the
changes were going to go across
all the
components.  I got to say, it
was really difficult to debug in
the DOM.  I did most of my work
in the inspector.  When you're
not using Mac and class names,
it's difficult to tell what
you're looking at, even when you
know what you're looking at.
Because the styles are jammed in
with the rest of your elements.
And interestingly enough, the
components themselves don't
really lend themselves to
outside use in other code bases.
You're placing these styles
directly in line.  You would
have to go in and reconfigure
every single one by hand in
order to use it somewhere else.
And another interesting thing
that we found was that
performance was not very good.
A page full of inline styles
were each tagged and needs to be
parsed is going to be less per
perform
mant than loading a single style
sheet.  CSS-in-JS is pretty hot
right now, but in 2015, it was
on fire.  There were not a lot
of libraries.  I think at the
time that we were developing,
aphrodite had just come out.  I
think it's evolved quite a
bit.
So, style components weren't
around in 2015, but I think they
represent a giant leap forward
in CSS-in-JS libraries, so I'm
going to talk about that today.
So here we have our same frame
component.  Should be very
familiar with this component by
now.  But there's a big
difference in the way we're
putting this together.  So style
components actually utilizes
tagged template literals to use
real CSS and Cree act normal
React components.  We're
importing style from style
components.  We're importing
that library, and we're able to
construct a wrapper component
that applies the styles to a
section tag.  So
wrapper=style.section.  In the
DOM, that's going to generate a
mapped class name that maps to
those styles.  So it's a big
difference in the way that you
handle inline styles.  It's
generating a CSS style sheet.
So at_run time is loading at
your document, and applying the
class name to the styles.
So, I would say that how you
structure your component folder
is going to be a team decision.
And in most cases, should be
decided before you ever touch
the styles.  In this example,
I've actually broken that
component down even
further.
Here, the way we've broken
it down is we've constructed
each piece, and then I'm just
building in my render, each
piece of that component.  Here,
I've actually broken out each
one as its own separate entity,
and I'm bringing them into my
index file.  I can use these
over and over again in other
components and other areas and
build like a bunch of le go
blocks.  This allows more
flexibility and scalability long
term as you can easily move
those pieces around to construct
larger components.
I think style components
have a lot going for them.  And
CSS-IN-JS libraries do, too.
They allow you to write without
context shifting.  It also
enforces best practices by
reproving that mapping between
the HTML and the CSS.  Because
you're building small, purely
presentational components,
they're independent and
reusable.  Single-use class
names -- there we go! Single-use
class names make naming easier
with no chance of collision.
You have containers and
components, so you're separating
out your presentation from your
logic.  Style components
actually has basic SASS support
so you can do things with
variables, mix-ins, nestings.
There's a lot of cool features
there.  It even has native
mobile support and theme
support.
So there are some cons.
Choosing CSS-IN-JS -- is one
choice followed
by another
choice.  CSS modules
question the So,is,what
should I use? It
many.  depends.
I know you were looking for one
answer today, but there really
is no one answer.  I think it
really does depend.  There are a
lot of choices out there.  I
think you need to start by
asking the right questions.  So,
what are the mental models on
the team? A mental model is
based on belief not facts.  It's
are based on what users
think they know about a system.
And understanding each person's
mental model of styling can
foster productive conversations.
I think having a good idea of
how each person sees styling so
that you can speak to their view
on it a little bit better can
help you in those
conversations.
And I think it's also
important to acknowledge the
different skill levels on a
team.  If there's a mixture of
skill levels, as I said, a lot
of times you have designers that
are implementing your CSS, and
may not be as comfortable in
JavaScript.  Simplicity and
clarity can really help everyone
stay together.  If you're a
group of highly skilled devs,
then I think introducing new
technologies or complexities
probably won't pose much of a
problem.  And what do you need
to build? Make sure you
understand what you actually
need to build.  There's a lot of
pressure in our industry to know
the latest framework, language,
or whatever tech is making the
rounds today.  And it can be
really tempting to jump on the
latest technology.  So before
adding libraries and building
complex styling
systems to make usability, make
sure it's something you really
need.
Start as simply as possible, and
build from there.
And how you plan on
structuring your project.  React
is not opinionated.  It will
help you determine the style
method that is going to work
best for you within the rest of
your team.  Are they going to be
kept together? Will you have the
need for access to global
styles? Is that something you
anticipate having to have? And
these are a couple of
considerations.  Think about
these things before you jump
into making that styling
decision.
Even more importantly is to
create the right environment.
Building things successfully
requires more than the right
technology.  It really does
require the right environment.
I think there are four
ingredients to making that
happen.  First, avoid dogma at
all costs.  Taking extreme
positions on a subject creates
tension and defensiveness before
conversations even get started.
Build trust.  Taking risks is
really hard to do.  It's even
harder if you don't trust the
people you're
doing it with.
Embrace change.  Whenever you
feel the urge to push back on
something, lean in instead.  You
will be surprised how much you
will learn and how many friends
you will make along the way.  I
think lastly, you need to be
vulnerable.  It's okay to say
you don't understand something
or that you don't see the
benefit in it.  Being honest
opens up the chance for greater
understanding for everyone on
the team.
I think it's also important
to remember -- I love this
quote.  Having a thoughtful
understanding of CSS to begin
with is going to help you build
greater things.  Whether you do
it using CSS SASSless or
CSS-IN-JS, understanding what
you're building and how to use
it is very important.  Thank
you.
Sarrah.
I have one question for you.
You mentioned how to
[ Applause ]
>> style React components. It's
a very divisive topic.  You
mentioned great tools to
convince team members.  What if
you have to work with someone
who still does not agree with
you? What do you do? How do you
not lose friends that way?
>> Not everyone is going to be
your friend.  I think at that
point you have to agree to
disagree so or commit.  Whether
you agree or the other team
member agrees, as long as you
all commit to making that work
and moving forward with it, it's
going to be just fine.
>> First acknowledge that
not everyone can be my friend.
And then commit to my decision?
Okay.
>> Commit to that decision
and keep going with it.
Otherwise you will go round and
round and refactoring, and it's
going to be a much,mess.
>> Makes total sense. Thanks a
lot, Sarrah.
go into a ten-minute break.  The
next talk starts at about
[ Applause ]
>>10:40. Thank you.
[ Break ]
we
will
@smiley845 with @whitecoatcapxg
>> Hello. How's everyone doing?
Everyone's still quiet.
That's all right.  So I'm really
actually looking forward to this
next talk.  As JavaScript
developers, we get used to a
certain way of doing things.  We
get used to pushing pixels and
working on complex UIs and all
of that.  This talk aims to push
the boundaries of what you think
JavaScript is, and take you a
step beyond web apps and
websites and hopefully inspire
you to, you know, further push
the envelope on writing and
utilizing JavaScript.  Please
join me
in welcoming to the stage our
next speaker.
>> Ow amaze -- how amazing is
in welcoming to the stage our
nextJSConf so far? Let me start
with a confession.  JavaScript
is amazing and weird and
peculiar and awesome and
strange.  JavaScript is the only
one I know
like this.  We constantly
complain when people contribute
things.  And JavaScript is
everywhere.  So my browser runs
JavaScript.  My server runs
JavaScript.  My TV runs
JavaScript.  My washing machine?
Well, that doesn't run
JavaScript.  It probably runs C
+ +.
It can even run weapons guidance
systems.  Only if you're using
JQuery, that is.  They haven't
uploaded the code to GitHub, so
I haven't tested it yet.  But it
looks legit.  JavaScript is
ubiquitous.  Everybody uses it.
You don't have to trust what I'm
saying.  You can trust this book
from 2003, literally titled,
"how to do everything with
JavaScript cooties.  It
-- it teaches everything.
So JavaScript does a lot of
things.  But I'm here to show
you maybe things that you
weren't -- you thought weren't
possible with JavaScript or kind
of off of the beaten path.  The
cool thing about technology is
that they allow all of our
ideas, the good and interesting
ones as well as the dumb and
silly ones.
Okay.  I come to you from
Tel Aviv Israel, wheresilly
ones.
Okay.  I come to you the spoken
language is Hebrew.  You might
not notice, but my name, Opher,
means fun.  Like Bambi.
I'm not sure why I told you
that.  It seemed important at
the time.  I'm a designer,
musician, and sometimes a gamer.
It turns out that JavaScript is
really good for all of these
things.  So that makes me a
developer.  In my day to day, I
work at a company called echo as
a creative developer.  What is
that? According to some
definitions, those being my
definitions, that means someone
who works with other creative
people like film maker, game
makers, musicians, designers to
do all sorts of cool interactive
things on the web.  And I want
to start by telling you a little
story about myself and how I got
into web development.  So the
year was 1997 or 1998, and I was
15 years old.  I was was
spending a weekend at my
grandfathers.  It was a there
that I found a book about HTML.
It was mesmerizing.  I remember
hours of notepad and Netscape4
trying to figure out what this
thing does.  And I read about
amazing technology called links
that allowed you to connect one
page to another web page, and
that seemed amazing.  The
problem is, it didn't work so
well for me.  I didn't know what
was the problem.  I knew I did
something wrong, but I wasn't
sure what was wrong.  And then
it hit me after a few hours.
You see, it's not called a HIRF
element, but a RIF element.
That makes so much more sense.
You understand why I didn't have
a girlfriend until the age of
20.  But fast forward a few
weeks later, and I had my first
website up on geocities.  Does
anyone remember geocities? Yeah,
I don't care.  It looked kind of
something like this.
Actually, it looked more
like this.  And you're laughing
at this because it's hilarious.
We didn't have fancy technology.
We didn't have CSS or the cloud
or have any idea what we're
doing.  We had to build our
websites with nested tables.  I
mean these kinds of nested
tables.  And not long after,
like I honed my skills, I worked
on making websites in the early
or late '90s, that is.  And I
finally as a teenager was able
to make some pocket money by
making websites for companies.
So, like, one of the first
websites I've ever made, an
actual company paid me actual
money for this thing.  I don't
know why it looks like this.
Maybe shoe-shaped side bars were
all the rage back then.  But the
funny thing about this is it has
a button that allows you to turn
off JavaScript.  That's an
amazing feature.  But okay.
Enough about me and my sense of
nostalgia.  Let's talk about
JavaScript.  What is JavaScript?
It allows us to add
functionality to websites.  Turn
them from static things to
interactive experiences.  Take a
look at this simple phone number
input, for example.  It's styled
nice with CSS.  But, this has a
slight issue.  If you want to
use this, you need to point your
mouse at the input and then, you
know, use the keyboard to input
your numbers.  And, like, that's
inefficient.  It's inconvenient.
Maybe we can add buttons so that
you don't have to use the
keyboard if you don't want to.
That's easily solved with
JavaScript.  Let's add buttons.
Problem
solved.  I know what you're
thinking.  Like, this is a joke.
This is an inefficient method of
inputting numbers.  I hear you.
Let's fix that.
Let's make this more efficient
with JavaScript.  There.  We're
done.  And I know.  We're like,
we're already there.  JavaScript
gives us so much power and
strength.  We can make this just
better for all of our users.  We
can just, you know, it's
endless.
So I studied design at the
academy of arts and design in
Jerusalem, which is one of the
best design schools in Israel,
with one of the worst design
logos in Israel.  I don't know
what they were thinking.  I
can't even... When I studied
there, I came to realize, how
amazing would it be if you could
connect technology and art? And
what technologies allow us to do
that? Check out this example.
Here we see, using
canvas and JavaScript, an
interactive art work.  Every
time you click, you get
something completely new.
So every user that just plays
with it gets his or her own
artwork.  How amazing is that?
That's JavaScript.  That's just
code.  Just JavaScript.  And
this creates these amazing
patterns.  You can take this a
step further.  You can transform
this into 3D.  So this one from
the Google arts team generated
machines via JS and web JL and
JavaScript.  So every time you
click generate, you get this new
machine, a beautiful thing that
is generated from seemingly
randomness.  Or another example
would be this example where you
have procedurally generated
old-timey airplanes.  So every
time you click on the next
button, you get this new flying
machine.  That's super cool.  If
you want to learn more about
generating things, I definitely
recommend you to take a time
machine and go back into the
talk yesterday.  If you don't
have that, when talks are up,
you should check that.
So, those are all personal
experiences.  But JavaScript can
do so much more.  It can go out
of your personal monitor and
turn into a public thing.  So
this work by a Polish born, San
Francisco-based digital artist
lets players and generate 3D
objects using the tools.  This
is a public art piece in a
public space.  And users can
then take the thing
that they can print in the 3D
printer.
You can go bigger than that.
There's a country somewhere
close to the north pole, or so I
heard, called Iceland.  And
sometimes they do a conference
where you can actually paint on
the building where the
conference is at.  If you ever
get a chance, I definitely
recommend going to that
conference.  But art is a really
good way to learn and understand
things.  It's -- it serves as a
good way and a learning tool.
So this is a project that I
made while I was studying there.
And I was obsessed with the idea
of evolution.  Evolution is a
hard concept to understand and
visualize, because you have,
like, mutation and survival of
the fittest and time and
generation.  I thought maybe I
can create something that will
help me understand it.  So I did
this little code with some
JavaScript.  And this has
digital creatures with very
simple rules.  Big creatures eat
little creatures.  Little
creatures eat food.  Little
creatures run away from big
creatures.  From simple rules,
you get this
amazing system, which it's kind
of like a virtual aquarium that
you look at.  And all of these
emerging patterns arise, and
it's mesmerizing -- and simple
JavaScript.  I thought okay.
How can we take that a step
further? And I turned this into
3D.  3D is always nicer.  But
the cool thing about that is the
web is all about sharing.  So
you can share your experience
with someone else.  I thought if
I have my aquarium and you have
yours, what would happen if
these two eco-systems were to
meet? If I have my creatures,
and I open a portal up to your
browser where you have your
creatures, how would the two
ecosystems interact? Would one
of them completely obliterate
the other? That's super cool and
something you can do by typing
JavaScript and hitting in
refresh a lot of times.  How
amazing is that? But there are
different ways to do learning.
One of these is machine
learning.  And JavaScript also
allows you to do that.  So think
JavaScript might not be the
first thing you of when you
think about machine learning.
But it turns out that it's a
possibility.  So deeplearn.js is
a machine learning library in
JavaScript.
And I'm going to show you an
example here.  The way it works
is that I'm going to play a
little melody, and then via
machine learning, we're going to
hear another melody that's based
on the one I just played.  Let's
try this out.
[ Notes playing... ]
I didn't say it's going to
be a good melody, just that it's
going to work.  If we're on the
topic of music, music videos.  I
remember, again, as a kid, being
glued to the screen watching MTV
and
and those all were passive
experiences.  But the web allows
us to be interactive.
ThisVH1, is an old but really
cool example where you have 2D
and 3D animation, or wherever
you point the mouse, the stream
of animals run around on the
building.  And that way every
user gets his or her's own
personal experience.
And it doesn't end there.
This video clip for arcade fire
"Reflector" uses web GL and
cheaters, wherever you point the
mouse, there's an image
collector there.  And also some
3D where the dancer in the video
has this 3D thing overlaid on
top of her, which you can play
her.  Super cool stuff.  And the
options are endless.  This video
by real Estate is an actual
canvas that you can paint on.
Here I
tried to paint the sky blue.
This is really hard ren the
video keeps moving.  But it
gives you something to play
with.  You're creating art on
top of someone else's art.  This
is something that is only
possible due to web technology.
The next project is
something I'm really proud of.
This is the official video for
bob
Dilan's like a rolling stone.
The characters in the video are
lip syncing to the song.  And
the end user can pick which
channel to watch.  So instead of
watching one music video, you're
kind of creating your own
personal music video.
And again, this is like web
video.  It's just a video player
in JavaScript, and there are
challenges here, but it's just
pointing your browser somewhere
and seeing this.
Cool.
You can clap.  It's okay.
That's one of the things
we do.
One of the ultimate forms of
interactive entertainment is
video games.  A subject close
and dear to my heart.  And video
games come in all forms and
sizes.  Video games can be
something really small
like this mini game and website
for magicians where they use
canvas
and HTML to create some element
while you're interacting with
the website.  Or a video game
can be like a 2D thing.  This is
a game I made to teach kids
concepts in evolution.  Have I
mentioned that I like evolution
already? Never mind.  This is
done with 2D library called
phaser, which is based on a
render called pixie.  You can
take this to 3D.  So this is an
actual 3D pinball game running
in the browser.  The interesting
thing here is there is physics
involved.  There is a library in
the background actually doing
the calculations.  So you have
physical simulation running in
the browser.  But everything
that we just saw is a
single-player experience.  It's
just you sitting in front of
your computer or mobile or
whatever, playing.  But the web
is all about connecting people
and sharing.  So the natural
step from this is multiplayer
games, players that have many
players.  This one called wonder
by a game developer.  It gives
you control over a tribe.  And
then you fight other tribes for
resources and land.  And that's
super cool.  Games are usually
written in things like C or C +
+, but then you have to download
drivers and update your graphics
card.  But what if you could
point your browser and just play
with someone else without having
to download anything?
That is what I had in mind when
I wrote this.  It is a server
and client that allows people to
create their own online, web
video games without having to
worry about writing net code or
synchronization and all the
other things I had to pull my
hair out.  What can you do with
lance? This is a game I made
with lance.  It's called
sprocket leak.  Each player
controls a car, and these cars
actually play soccer.  And this
runs with 3D physics engine
running on the server on the
client.  And again this is all
web technologies.  This is all
stuff that you can do with just
notepad.  You shouldn't do this
with Notepad, but you can if you
want to.
Okay.  Another really cool
technology that's up and coming,
but also out there is web
assembly or its precursor, ASM.
Which essentially allows you to
take other languages like C or C
+ +, or could be anything, and
compile them to anything that
the browser can understand.  And
you have the browser running
something far more effective at
computation.  What does this
help us with? An example would
be porting the entire unreal
really going is to be  great for
a lot of things that need real
game engine.  juice powering it.
I'm excited about things that
had to do with virtualization
and running in a browser.  So
bear with me.  What if you could
run Windows 3.11 in a browser.
How amazing would that be? So
you could open up Paint and do
something or Slider.  You could
completely reimagine how it was
when you were sitting in your
mom's basement in the '90s.  And
this gets us to the next
technology, which is web virtual
reality, or web VR.  Maybe
you've heard about this.  But
the way to learn about subjects
that I don't know is to -- the
way that I like is to look at
stock photos of that specific
thing.
So if we look at stock photos of
web VR, we can learn all sorts
of things.  For example, web VR
is taking a stroll in nature.
And maybe we have rainbows
coming out of your crotch.  Or
maybe web VR is sometimes being
attacked by really old phones.
Or maybe you don't need to put
VR goggles to be in web VR, but
maybe you take headphones and
put them on your eyes and point
at something and that works just
as well.  But VR and web VR
specifically is all about
putting you inside a virtual
world.  In this example, you're
in this musical landscape, where
you have -- sound? Okay.  And
we have these cute, tiny
creatures where everyone has its
own little sound.  And you can
kind of play around with them.
And you are completely immersed
in this thing.  But virtual
reality is often times a product
of 3D models and something
that's completely virtual.  And
at work, I did something really
cool.  It's this project called
Broken Night, which is a
live-action film which was shown
at tribeca film festival last
year.  You're inside the film,
and you can control it.  So the
plot for this without too many
spoilers is there's a couple who
had an argument and coming back
home.  And then there's an
intruder in the house.  And you
get to live that moment.  So you
have, like, for example the two
characters, the man and the
woman.  And she takes the gun.
And then as a viewer,
you see the project splits into
two.
And wherever you look, that's
where the story is going to take
place.  Does the guy get the
gun? Does the girl get the gun?
You get to choose.  And then you
see with this interactive video,
the story that you would prefer
to see.  The story is not
linear.  It's completely
interactive.  Cool right?
This leads us to our next thing,
which is web augmented reality.
Or as I like to call it, web-AR.
If virtual reality is about
putting you in the virtual
space, augmented reality is
about taking the virtual space
and putting it in the real
world.  This example allows you
to take a tablet and point it at
a kid's coloring book, and
whatever the kid draws comes to
life in 3D.  So recent
developments in AR allow you to
actually do that, or potentially
do that in the browser.  There
was a talk about this by Raisa
yesterday.  We talked about web
VR.  And we talked about web AR.
And today there's a new buzz
word.  If you combine these two,
it is now called web XR.  Or
WebEx tended
ed -- web extended reality.  I
know that Mozilla is pushing
hard on a standard to progress
this forward.  This is super
cool stuff.
So the last thing we're
going to talk about is the
physical web, or the internet of
thingies.  There are a lot of
interesting stuff going on
there.  So one
of these is Nobot, which is a
movement which aims to get
JavaScript on actual robots.
So, for example, if you have
robots, and you have Node, and
if your computer is in Spanish,
then you can actually control
the robot via JavaScript.  And
that's pretty cool.  Or, you can
do something more, you know,
something better.  You can make
a cat remote control.  So all
you need to do in order to get
that is you need the Johnny 5
JavaScript library.  And you
also probably need a cat.
That's a requirement.  Or, how
about controlling a drone from
your browser on your phone? So
this is done via web Bluetooth.
This example shows us how he is
using JavaScript on his browser
on his phone to connect to a
drone and fly it.  He didn't
download any app to do this,
just like JavaScript API.  And
this works today on mobile
Chrome and also on Samsung
internet, which turns out is a
browser.  Super cool that you
can do that.
So everything that I just
showed you is out there in the
wild.  You can just use that
right now.  What does the future
hold? What's coming up next?
So, according to an HBO HBO
sci-fi show about AI robots that
run a theme park, these are
written using React.  I saw
Dan's talk yesterday.  He didn't
say anything about robots, but
maybe that's in the next
version? I don't know.
Hopefully.  Yeah.  Fingers
crossed.  But other upcoming
technologies?
What allows you to connect
peripherals directly to the
browser? Web NFC for near field
communication from the browser
or web MIDI for the music people
among us.  And I wanted to end
with something that gives you a
little perspective.  This was
the first web
server ever that the team used.
It literally had a sticker that
said "this is the internet.
Don't power it down."
This was the first website that
was used that it showed.  And
you know, what a way that we
have done from that day to what
we can do today with what
technology is.  That started
there, and here we are.  400
people who are passionate about
web technologies coming together
to meet in Iceland to talk about
this thing that we are
passionate about.  How amazing
is that? I'm going to leave you
with a parting gift.  An idea
that might, again, not be the
best.  But it's definitely not
the worst.  And that is
JavaScript dance party!
[ Music ]
Okay.  Thank you so
much.
[ Applause ]
before you leave, before I
relinquish this stage, my
friend, I had to show her that I
had more fun than her.  I'm
going to take a selfie with you,
and you're going to make it
appear as if you've had the time
of your life in this talk.  And
then I am going to win.  Because
winning is important in
marriage! Okay.  Okay.  Ready?
One, two, three! Raise your
hands! Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you so much for that
talk.  I am definitely really
inspired to play with all of the
technologies that you've
introduced.  So I wanted to ask
about what kind of experiences
do you think that you're looking
forward to in terms of like web
XR and web AR in the world of
mixing art and JavaScript?
>> Yeah, I think the interesting
things have already happened
when the technologies are super
ubiquitous where AR is not just
in one form, and the forms are
strong enough that it will be
common knowledge that you go up
to a store or open up a book and
something pops out of it using
your phone.  I think that will
be really cool in the near
future.
>> I think so, too. So our next
talk is happening around --
what time is it? 11:20.  So go
take a break.  Drink water, get
some coffee, and come back here
around 11:20.  Thank you.
Live Captions by:
@smiley845 with @whitecoatcapxg
... we get a huge traffic spike
at that point in time.  We get a
lot of hits on the website.  A
lot of traffic comes in.  is the
To give you an idea, this kind
of numbers that we -- oh.
Slides are almost half cut off.
Sorry about that.  Just a
second.  Can someone
check this?
I guess, I can carry on in the
meantime.  All right.  So,
getting back to the content.  We
have it on 150 million
registered users, and we have
around 200 million visits over
the five days of sale that we
have.  In those kind of events,
we usually sell close to half a
million units of specific
devices in under 15 seconds.
That's a lot of traffic coming
in at the exact same time.  That
makes the concept
of scaling important to us.
Technically scaling, this is a
definition I got from another
book.
Scalability is the capability of
a system to handle a growing
amount of work or its potential
to be enlarged to accommodate
that growth.  It could be a
system interface, a process, an
application.  Why should it
concern the JS
community? So, recently, JS is
running in the browsers until
recently, and that meant it was
already distributed.  A lot of
users visited a website at the
same time.  It's a central
location where all the traffic
comes in and you run into a lot
of issues.  The next is an
article on medium.  And he
mentioned that the concept of
observability.  He mentions
It tends to be less tested and a
more -- a new entry into that
picture.
[ Captioner is awaiting
audio
reconnection... ] shifting to
application
code.
manager.  Now what happens is if
you're rendering on the
server, bandwidth usage can grow
really fast.  This is a graph
from one
of our load tests.  And what
happens here is that the numbers
on here, what happens if you are
serving 1,000of our load tests.
And what happens here is
kilobyte, and your machine is
serving 100 requests per second
and you have 100 machines in
your cluster, that output will
be 10gigabits pre second.  If
you have another layer in the
middle.  That layer may not be
able to handle that load.  So
you need to make sure that your
end-to-end chain in the graph
can support whatever load you're
putting on them.
You might -- so an easy way to
solve this problem, and an easy
way we found was compression.
So you compress the HTML going
out of your Node servers.
Compress the amount of data
you're sending out.  And
compressing the HTML is a good
idea.  So the easiest way to do
that is drop in the compression
module, and you're good to go.
Not really.  We tried this as an
experiment, and it doesn't work
very well.  What happens is the
compression module has a high
CPU cost.  The nodes cannot take
anymore requests while the
stream is still being
compressed, which is really bad.
It will just reject those
requests.  What did we do? We
found another solution, which is
to have a proxy capable of
compression.  It is highly
efficient, and it's very
effective.  You can customize
these kind of tools to have
varying compression levels.  And
for us, another benefit was that
these are engine X crosses.  It
has a proxy cache, which you can
use to cache static
files.  So this is what that
likes like.
You have node processes, a
process manager in front of it,
and you have a proxy cache or a
compression layer in front of it
before it goes out of the
machine itself.  Now how do you
find these kind of issues? The
key here is providing.  And that
can lead you to many other
issues, also.  So what happens
here is you need to understand
your host operating system
in-depth.  Like I mentioned
before, why is this important?
Like why does the host operating
system of your server,  why is
it relevant tofront-end
developers? We're in node, and
we need to understand the
concept that when you serve a
file, when you're running an
application server, you are
using ports and sockets to do
that.  And there's a limit to
how many upstream and downstream
connections you can make at any
given time.  So you can use
built-in
units.  The soft command gives
you a list of open files.  And a
watch command lets you watch
many.
Frequently.
You can just watch the output.
What happens here is if you
watch this and run a load test,
you will see that you hit an
upper limit.  Everything is a
file in UNIX.  Every port you
open, every connection you make,
it really can be presented as a
file in your system if you're
using a UNIX-based server.
There's a limit to the number of
file descriptors.  Since there's
a limit for stability reasons,
this will happen.  You have a
command, which is the user
limit, which will ship with very
same
defaults, right? This is what
the defaults look like.
This is a very short list, which
is getting cut off, actually.
The essential idea is there is a
limit to the file size that you
can have.  The maximum number of
open files you can have, which
is a default of 1024.  And the
hope  open files limit includes
the number of ports and sockets.
You can increase the limits.
You should.  You should have
better limits.  The 1024 are
very low and don't actually make
sense.  You do that.  You will
hit that limit at some point.
So the next idea is that you
have to reduce the usage and the
number of ports that you're
opening and reduce the number of
sockets that you're keeping
open.  So the key idea is to
optimize your application
itself.  These are the things
that we looked at.  And these
are low-hanging fruit.  You can
reduce the number of codes by --
request user connections from
the client site.  This also
saves time.  You don't have to
do the connection handshake
again and again for every
request.  And it looks very
simple.  Essentially, whatever
you're passing to whatever
network you're making from the
server, you add a layer and give
it a time-out.  And this allows
you to reuse connections between
the
load balances on the machines,
too.  The load balancer itself
will have a limit on how many
ports it can open.  Usually
those machines are not in your
control, so it's best to
minimize the usage of those
resources.  The next concept is
connection pooling.
Essentially, connection pooling
is the concept of reusing
sockets on your site, the server
side.  You pass a custom agent
to fetch.  When you're making
code, you can essentially, the
fetch command defaults to its
own agent.  If you don't parse
this.  It does not have the
concept of keep alive
connections.  Here you can say
you want a connection to be kept
alive, and how many connections
can be kept open at a time? And
this helps when you are making
fetch calls.  A report is a
short end end point.  The friend
will assign it in a different
range and they will have
different limits.  For limits,
it's around 32,000 to 61,000.
The OS will return the next
available port, which can be a
counter or from  a pool of
ports.
The TCP protocol, we had a great
call yesterday about finite
state machines.  This is what it
looks like.  The key idea is you
have important states like
established time rate and close
rate.  Those are very important
rates that your connection can
reside in.  Essentially, what
that means is the way -- the
reason it works this way is that
when you make a TCP
connection, it's a complex
connection.  If your server
closes the connection, the
server has to wait for a final
packet that it has been closed.
So, TCP has a default
time out on both the server and
the client.  If you do simple
math based on 30,000.
You will see that you run out of
veilable
ports.  As soon as you reach 400
unique requestses per second.
Application server will not be
able to take more requests.  And
the key idea is to just monitor
and
profile everything.  The moment
the time rate connections and
close rate connections show up.
Your CPU might be free to handle
more requests, your operating
system says I cannot give you
anymore ports.  So these two
things help us a lot.  So that
brings me to the next idea on
CPU.  We were
talking about ports and sockets,
but what about band
idth.  The most obvious idea is
first thing first, make
sure you are running the right
one in production.  If you
don't, you get a bunch of
things.  You get a bunch of
extra debugging and monitoring
things which you don't need.  It
slows down your code.  And check
for it in every build that that
is in fact the case.  So we have
to provide it continuously.
Node has a built-in profiler.
You run it with node--prof.
Let's say you have a sample that
looks like this, and this comes
from node's own
documentation.
Essentially just running a hash
on the password.  And when you
run a profiler on this, the kind
of output you can expect is
something like this.  What this
tells you is on the
C++line, not JavaScript line.
It's not your fault that you're
using so much CPU.  But the idea
is be sure what kind of
liabilities you use and what
they do internally.
They may be blocking your CPU or
main thread.  When you dig
deeper, you can find things
like this.  Maybe you switch
this output in the library or
push this off to a separate
server or thread, and you can
get your application server to
take more requests.  Right? And
you can do this using a lot of
other tools.
So this output is not very
user-friendly.  You can use the
other tools.  But it is not very
Mac friendly.  A lot of
developers use Mac, but D trace
doesn't work well on Mac with
frame drops.  There's a tool
called 0X
which generates well on Mac.
It's very easy to
install.  It will add injections
into the code, and it will give
you this kind of an output.
This is a flame chart.  It
install.  It will add injections
into the code, and shows you the
amount of time on the X axis,
amount of time on the CPU.
This will be familiar to you.
It's a vertical mirror of the
Chrome's flame chart.  It's
another version of that.  When
we ran this tool on the load, we
found some interesting facts.
We found that the string was
taking almost 60% of the CPU
time, and that's an atomic
function that we cannot skip.
We were rendering heavy pages on
the server with a lot of known
nodes.  There's no way to avoid
that.  Maybe with streaming and
fiber, we can do that.  That's
what we will be trying next.
The interesting factor is
serialization and
deserialization of JSON were
spending much of our time.  And
we moved to nginx as a tool.
These things make a huge
difference.  Right?
So that's that.  And garbage
collection also plays an
important role.  So you will
find all of that in these kind
of flame charts.  And very easy
to look at the flame charts is
that a flat top, like a plateau
on this landscape is a bad
thing.  If you have a plateau,
that means that one function is
monolithically spending that
much time on the CPU.  Most of
the sharp peaks are generally
good.  Right? Good.
So
next idea is trying to avoid.
Maybe if it's a small enough
server file, cache it, but avoid
reading from the disk.
Try to use async as much as
possible.  Another thing that we
noticed is we were using
third-party loading services,
which on digging deeper, we
found out that they were
actually loading in sync.  It
was a synchronous
command.  Make sure you know
that you're not inadvertently
using something that will cause
you a lot of disk use.  Monitor
your graphs and systems closely
and watch your rates  and what
the disksare rated for.
The next topic I wanted to
mention is memory.  Essentially,
it's a simple idea.  Memory
usage should stabilize at a
given request rate.  You can use
a tool.  Essentially, a small
library for node, which allows
you to sort of -- it just raises
events when it detects a memory
leak.  And it's really useful.
It's able to tell you that there
is a memory leak, and you need
to find out if there is a memory
leak.  How you do that is using
the Chrome time line.  If you
connect the Chrome process or
universal JavaScript, then you
can code in Chrome directly, and
find out by taking heap
snapshots what is getting in
your program memory.  Then from
that you can look at allocation
time line, so profiles of
actually figuring out what is
causing the leak.  Cool.
So that was the four pillars,
the four major bottlenecks that
you can run into.  Now a very
important factor is that you
need to have realtime monitoring
for your systems.  What I mean
by that is that you can have a
load test going on in a machine.
When you actually run the load,
make sure you monitor your CPU,
RAM, disk usage, see what it
looks like.
But make sure you leave some CPU
for the OS.  If you run at 90%
CPU usage, it's usually not a
good idea.  You need to allow
the operating system, for node
to do garbage collection.  And
node to do its own tasks, and
allow for traffic bursts, which
can happen with real traffic.
Ideally, we have seen if you
keep 20% CPU, and actually
programmatically start rejecting
requests when you reach that
limit, it's a good idea and
prevents systems from shutting
down by hitting their own
limits.
So, key take aways from this
would be that you need to load
profile, fix, and repeat.  Put
load on your systems, profile it
continuously, fix those issues,
and just repeat.  And a little
dev ops goes a long way.  As
front end devs, a
lot of times we have inhibition
on monitoring stuff, and not
understanding how low level
items work.  What I have seen
helped us a lot, it's more and
more important that we
understand how the back-end
servers work and what we can do
to optimize them.  Cool.  So
that's all from my side.  The
slides are here.  And that's my
Twitter handle.  Reach out to me
if you have any
questions.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you so much for that.
Do you think that any --
are there any current node
features, either being actively
worked on or in the future that
would help
with a lot of what you
discussed?
>> Definitely. I think there
are a lot of features, including
some mentioned yesterday that
will definitely help us a lot.
You can think of streaming
requests and responses.  You
cannot block your main thread.
Whatever you can do to avoid
blocking the main thread,
because that allows you to take
a request.  If the request
cannot reach the node process,
there is no point in trying to
handle it.  There are a lot of
node features coming up that
will help us.
>> Awesome. Thank you so much.
>> Okay.
>> And so it's come to my
favorite part of the day, which
is food.  Lunch is the greatest.
So lunch would be, I think, in
this floor and also we still
have swag on the fifth floor.
So if you want to get your swag
or backpacks or hats, you can go
upstairs.  Thank you
so much.
[ Break ].
[ Break ].  Live Captions
by:
like you did my job.  I didn't
feel the need to come up here.
But, so, for our next talk, this
is going to be a really fun one.
I feel like the topics always
discuss the limits of the
browser and JavaScript and
pushing that
@smiley845 with @whitecoatcapxg.
[ Applause ]
>>
to the edge.
Not only are we going to get a
talk, but also a performance by
our speaker.  So please give it
up for Armagan.
>> Thank you so much.
Welcome everybody.  Maybe we
could start with
a song.  Would you like that?
Let's start with an easy one.
Something that hopefully a lot
of people know.
[
Music ] pedal board jess.
Okay.  That didn't go as
well as
Music ]
planned.
or web.
Okay.  This one was
better.  Thank you.  Cool.
Let's get back to the
presentation.  So this talk is
called code, play, and rock n
roll.  I hope to code some and
play some guitar, and hopefully
we'll enjoy the show.  All
right.  Great.
So before we start, a
lot of you are familiar with the
scene, but this is what a real
pedalboard looks like.  These
are all tiny gadgets that shape
the sounds that we all know out
there.  And this is how it can
look in software in one of the
tools for products that I've
done called
pedals.io.  This is a
representation of real life
guitar pedals.  You saw two of
them in the short demo, and we
will add more, of course, delay,
reverb, and lots more in the
coming minutes.  I'm
Armagad, and I come from Berlin.
We are building electric
scooters like Vespa, but with
electric batteries.  I'm the
founder of a software school for
women.  And I like to play a lot
with code.
I have a lot of open-source
projects on GitHub that range
from brain signal processing to
audio processing to front-end
libraries and platforms as a
service and microservices and a
lot of other stuff.
So what is mid audio? This
is an amazing playground for us,
the other musicians.
So The API is basically
built into all of the major
browsers.  It givings you
everything you need to build
high-quality audio applications
that are like this, pedalboards.
Or full-fledged digital audio
stakeses, or game audio in a 3D
room where you can adjust the
position of the sound.  And you
can have specific start times
and end times for specific
samples so it matches with your
animations or characters.  And
you can do some production
applications or media production
applications.  Like DJ image
sync tools.  Anything you are
used to using on your computers
or on your phones or iPads or
tablets, they are available
through web audio API.  And you
can build any dream application
that you have in mind that
includes audio, as well as art
installation as well.  You can
combine it with the input that
comes from a camera, and you can
basically turn it into sound.
You can turn the pixels that the
camera captures and portray it
as sound samples or any kind of
sound effects.
If you have ever imagined
anything about audio, that's
available through web Audio.
This is what I had imagined, to
be able to play guitar effects
free, everywhere, without the
need of installation of a
software.  And basically, I made
it possible with web Audio API.
So
a little bit about Web Audio API
and its basic structure.  Web
Audio API is a network of nodes.
You create some nodes, and they
are either a source so that they
represent a signal like an MP3
file, for example, or an
oscillator, like a keyboard,
which is a source of sound.  Or
they are sound processing units,
sound processing nodes.  So
these can be, as you see here,
like a delay effect that is like
an echo that repeats the sound.
Or a gain effect that improves
or amplifies the sound.  Or
sound
filters that I will demo in a
couple of minutes that I can do.
At the end, there's a target, a
destination, an output, which is
your headphones or your
speakers, or it can be a
recording target so that you
can save whatever you created
with Web Audio to an MP3 file.
The idea is very simple.  You
create these nodes, and you set
some parameters, which is very,
very simple, extremely simple.
You don't have to know a lot of
math.  Actually, you don't even
have to know math for anything
except one special
node.  It is there to introduce
gain distortion effects.  You
connect them together, starting
from the source, from the
guitar, or of course, that's a
guitar for me.
But whatever source of input you
want.  Maybe it's
a mic or another audio file.
And you connect them however you
like to the output.  And
everything happens in
realtime.  Okay.
Okay.  So Web Audio holds a
lot of components.  Everything
has to happen within audio
context.  Anybody familiar with
canvas API? In order to draw
something to the screen, you
have to get ahold of the
context.  And other contexts are
basically the same.  In order to
do any audio application, you
need to have an audio
context.
You can have more than one,
multiple plugins or
applications.  Then there's the
context for you to be able to
record something, again, and a
lot of processing nodes,
processing units like
gain, delay, panner.  Panner is
used to direct the sound to
either left or right
channels.
Convolver is used to introduce
the
eco
-- echo effects.  A hole effect.
They are made possible by
filters.  And a convolver node
is used there.  You can have an
analyser node.  You can grab the
signal and look at the frequency
content, look at the power.  And
you can do various effects based
on that.  You can split them
into multiple channels, multiple
tracks, so that the graph can
get wider and wider as you want.
It has a lot of nodes.  And
lately, they also introduced
some audio worker.
So it's like a service worker.
It works in the background in a
separate thread.  And basically,
it allows you to implement your
own algorithms and your own
scripts or functions that will
run per sample.  But it will run
off-thread, so you won't see the
performance penalty.  So you
won't be using the main thread
of the browser.  But it's
parallel so that you can have
multiple of them.  It makes the
browser a very nice competitor
for digital audio workstations.
You can get real,
production-grade audio
applications right inside
the browser.  Okay.  Here's a
very small example.  You start
by creating a context.   You do
new audio context.  And as I
said, everything is hosted under
that context.  So, you can
create a game node, which will
amplify the incoming signal by
doing context.create gain.  And
you can connect it to the
destination, which is the
speaker output or whatever you
like, again.  Here's another
example to basically load an MP3
file and use it as the source.
You can create
a buffer source and load the
buffer that you downloaded from
the internet and use it
connected to the gain as the
input.  This basically gives you
a graph where the source is at
the beginning.  In the middle
you have the gain, and in the
end, you have the destination.
But this is basically as simple
as just loading an MP3 file.
Okay?
Let's talk about pedalboard.JS.
It is the first open-source Web
Audio framework.
I guess I did it in 2012.  Back
then, Web Audio API wasn't a
thing.  It couldn't capture
directly from your sound card.
And could only work with static
buffers.  But, those days are,
fortunately, behind us.  And six
years later, it's still one of
the best interactive libraries
out there.  Full disclosure, I
wrote it.  It's GPL licensed.
It has a very nice
documentation, both inside the
source code and as a read me.
And it has very nice
abstractions.  If you are into
building your own pedals, which
I am, you can build your own
pedals here very easily and make
it a part of the library.  Or
play with it however you like.
Anybody doing guitar
electronics, like their own
pedals? Nobody? Okay.
Interesting.  It's very fun.  I
started by doing real electronic
circuits for overdrive pedals,
and moved on to the digital
world, because this is a lot
easier.  So you have pedal
boxes, pots, meters you can
twist and turn around, switches
you can push, and LEDs that can
blink, and you bring these
together to make pedals.  This
is built on top of something
called Google closure library.
Anybody using that? One person.
You are my hero.  Anybody who
has used
it before? Another person.  It's
arguably the best user interface
library out there.  It's by
Google and it's what Gmail,
Google docs, and what all the
other serious Google tools are
built on.  It's like nothing
that all the other guys can do
out there.  But yeah, Google
closure compiler has invest
most, which rewrites from
scratch, doing a lot of
optimizations, just like a real
compiler, like a C compiler.
And it also optimizes for speed,
download speed, and for run time
performance.  So a
pedalboard.JS was built on this
because it was the best choice
in 2012.  I guess I want to
rewrite it now with ES6.  If
anybody wants to offer a hand,
that would be appreciated.  It
uses a MVVM architecture, which
is kind of out of fashion right
now in the
front-end world.
So you have a stage.  As the
audio context in pedalboard.JS,
everything starts with a stage.
Without a stage, there is no
musicianns.  Even if you are
playing in your bedroom, that's
your stage.  Then you have a
pedalboard that hosts your
pedals.  And you have some
boxes.  Usually they're empty,
so it's like a class, but you
can fill them and make them
guitar
pedals.  For example, a reverb
pedal is a box with inner
circuitry.  LEDs, pots, file
inputs.  Maybe the most
important one is the stream
input, which is the thing you
use to capture the sound of your
guitar or live instrument or
also a microphone.  So you can
do pretty fun effects with your
voice just in your browser.
Okay?
I'm not going to go into the
details here.  I'm going to show
you some code.  But before that,
I also want to talk about web
media API.  Anybody, please
raise your hands if you have
played with the web media API.
One, two, three.
Okay.  This is another fun API.
You can do anything with it.
You can grab any DY
-- DJ or musician gear or a drum
pad, or something like this.  So
this is also a media controller.
It's a wireless blue tooth MIDI
controller.
Basically, you can connect this
to the browser directly and get
some messages from that,
depending on which key you press
or which button you press, you
get a different message on your
browser.  You can use it for
scrolling pages or hiding adds
or, I don't know, photo
applications like photo
Forfilters. me, for example, I'm
really sick of editing tiny
sliders on my phone when I edit
photos.  Or in the computer with
a mouse, you have to click
something to change the
brightness of an image, for
example.  But if you have a MIDI
controller that has a knob that
you can turn, it's a lot simpler
to modify images or sound if you
are a DJ.
Basically the mixer that you see
before the musicians, they are
also MIDI controllers.  And they
can be reflected right in the
browser, and it's super easy to
get started.  These gears are
like, they start from $20 or
something? So you can get
extremely cheap MIDI gear.  And
use it as an external input
device to the browser, because
with a mouse, you can only do so
much.  But tactile  have ainput
is really good.  If you pad or a
slider or fader or a knob that
you can twist to, I don't know,
to turn on the volume of YouTube
videos or something.
It's really, really effective.
And of course, you can also do
some games
with it.  Here it is.
So this is a game I implemented
in one of the DJ gears.  The one
on the left is the real DJ pad.
The right is a browser.  So I
basically mirrored it in the
DOM.  So that's a snake game
that I play with a real DJ
device.  So you can turn the
lights on and off through the
browser.  It's connected over
blue tooth.  And yeah.  You can
do a lot of stuff
with it.  What does this look
like? Ill re it's really simple.
It gives you something that
inputs and  with it.  What does
this look
outputs.  You attach an event
handler.  There you get an event
every time something changes in
the MIDI device.  Likeoutputs.
You attach when you press a
button or turn a knob or
anything.  You get an event that
is not that significant except
for the data, which is an area
of three values or sometimes two
values.  And they are the
numbers, the channel that the
signal is coming in.  The node,
the program change signals, and
its value.  It's either zero or
any value up to 127.  It's very
simple.  And then you do
whatever you want with it.  And
of course, as you can imagine,
what I did
with that is
I connected it to my pedalboard,
thatand I can turn on and off my
pedals in realtime as
I play, because I don't have a
third hand yet.  So here is the
pedal.
That is the patch that I was
using.  First, I actually want
to show you how the -- yep.
So, if you see it there, the LED
is blinking.  It's turning off
and on.  And I can also turn on
and off the second one.  If I
long-press this, it will change
go to the second song so thatthe
patch.  So it will I can play
that one.  I can turn on and off
different pedals.  And the other
one has a very nice pedal called
a wa pedal.  Anybody familiar
with that? With the wawa pedal?
Good.  You should learn the wa
pedal.  Okay.  It's like
this device.  Everything is
apparently called a is also
pedal, but this called a pedal.
You can step on it.  You can
step on it to change the value.
And look at the second one.  I
hope you can see it.  The effect
knob changes as I move my pedal.
Which means, it opens or closes
the wa pedal depending on the
position.  Basically I use these
with my library to make some
some code.   see
Nowlet's
So, is it readable? From the
back? That's nice.  Thank you.
So again, it's very, very
simple.  I included
pedalboard.JS as a global
library.  This is a module, some
of the data components are
available in the global context
in the window.  So I call
something called a stage.  It
has its  own context.  So stage
creates its own audio context.
And that is what you use to
create your audio pedals.  You
create a pedalboard.  You use
the stream input to get
the guitar.  And you set the
board to the stage.  And then
you have
some pedals.
first  Thethere.
Yeah.  one is a noise gate.
Let's see.  So you have three
pedals out A noise gate
basically saves our ears.  When
you use distortion and
overdrive, there's a lot of buzz
and hum, and that's not ideal.
You use a noise gate to block
those noises, and it has a
switch that
Youoff. can change it, and it's
dynamically reflects in you can
toggle on and
the value.  You can change it
through
code.  Or through this pedal.
Let me try another one.
music playing ]
[ Nothing else matters by
Metallica... ]
it.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.  This is
pedalboard.JS, and this is what
you can do with the browser,
only a fraction of it.  I
encourage you to take a look.
Thank you
again.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you so much. I hope I
can try it later.  I play the
guitar as well.  I want to ask
you, for
people who want to learn more
about playing Web Audio online,
I know there's a ton of
resources out there to learn
more about it.  But what would
you recommend?
>> Chrome has a lot of
That's recommendations
collected in a list.  So
yes, it's on my site.
Web Audio has like 500 different
experiments that you can play
with, see the source code, and
enjoy and learn, of course.  So
that's the perfect place to
start.  It gives you a lot of
ideas to build with.
>> Awesome. Thank you so
much.
[ Applause ]
so we have a break for about ten
minutes.  Our next talk starts
at 1:40.  Go grab a drink, and
come back for more talks.
[ Break ]
Live Captions by:
@smiley845 with @whitecoatcapxg
>> Hello. Welcome back.
How's everybody doing? I have a
few announcements to make.
Later today we will have a
speaker panel, and that's
between
Anna Dan, and Martin.
That's going to be later today.
And you can submit questions
through Slido.com, and the event
code is Anna Dan, and Martin.
That's going to be later today.
And you can submit questions
JSConf.  Go submit your
questions, and we will discuss
them on stage.
And so anyways, to our next
talk.  I feel like our next talk
is very important and definitely
needs to be talked about more
often in the workplace and
everywhere else.  It givings us
-- gives us an overview of key
statistics in mental health and
efforts done by the nonprofit
organization called open
sourcing mental illness.
Let's give it up for Nara.
>> Can you all hear me okay?
All right.  My name is Nara
Kasbergen.  I'm here from
Washington D.C.  I'm actually
going to save most of my
introduction for the second part
of the talk.  I first want to
cover statistics and definitions
related to mental health to make
sure we're all on the same page
here.  I will go more into my
own story and why this is so
important to me.  The bulk of
the talk is going to be focused
on things all of us can do in
our own workplaces and lives.
Common sense, action-oriented
things that we can all put into
action to support mental health
better.  There's a short section
the end of things we all have in
to do together.  It's more
difficult and more aspirational,
but still needs to be done.
So first, what are we
talking about? If there's
anything that I want you to
walk away from here is this
statistic.  One in five adults
are walking around with a mental
illness.  It's one of the most
prevalent chronic health
conditions, but we really don't
ever talk about it.  To be
clear, when I say mental
illness, I'm talking about any
one of these.  Some of these you
may have heard of before, some
of these you may not have.
There's a phenomenon called
co-morbidities.  It means when
you have one of these, it often
makes you more prone to develop
another illness.  Depression and
anxiety.  ADHD
and anxiety often go together.
Two that I wanted to point out
specifically are autism spectrum
disorders and burn-out.  So
autism spectrum disorders are
kind of part of a bigger
umbrella term of mental
disorders, but they're often
accompanied by other things like
learning disabilities and
sometimes physical health
issues.  So they often require
their own kinds of treatments
and interventions.  So
organizations that focus on
activism around mental health
often focus around some of the
rest of these or autism spectrum
disorder specifically, because
they require more specialized
treatment.  I will not talk to
much about autism spectrum
disorders today, because the
organization I work with is
focused on others.  What I will
talk about is still relevant for
autism as well.  And obviously
we're going to be talking a lot
about the workplace, so I wanted
to call out the idea of
burn-out, especially in the
United States, where I come
from, the idea of burn-out was
introduced in the 1970s, there
was quite a bit of push back.
Saying it's silly that you can
get sick from working too much.
I looked at where are we at in
2018 and what does
the research say? And most
psychologists say that burn-out
is actually depression.  At the
end of the day when they control
for all kinds of factors, the
symptoms are essentially the
same.  It's depression from
prolonged stress from working so
much.  We don't have to say
necessarily, butdepression,
burn-out.  I figured since we
will be talking about the
workplace, it's an important
thing to know about.
A big problem with mental
illness is there's often
preconceived notions about what
that means.  If I say mental
illness to a stranger, chances
are they will think of something
like schizophrenia.  But
depression is one of the most
common mental illnesses and 13
times more prevalent than
schizophrenia.  There's lots of
misunderstanding about things
like the symptoms of depression.
We often associate it with
feelings of saddens, emptiness,
loss of pleasure and interest in
normal activities, and
tiredness.  But there's a whole
spectrum that can include things
like angry outbursts and
irritabilityirritability.
Insomnia or sleeping to much,
agitation and restlessness.
When women experience
depression,
they're more prone to experience
loss of interest in normal
activities, and men are more
likely to have theoutbursts.
Because angry  we don't often
associate those with depression,
men are more likely to not even
realize that they're suffering
from depression.
Another problem with
depression in particular is we
tend to shame people for feeling
this way.  And a lot of people
with depression often say that
they'll hear things like I can't
believe you are feeling sad when
kids in Africa are starving.
There's a rebuttal that does its
rounds on the internet.  Telling
someone not to be sad because
others have it worse is like
telling people that they can't
be happy because others have it
better.
Another really great
illustration of the stigma
against mental illness is from a
web comic.  It's called helpful
advice, and a subtitle if
physical illness were treated
like mental illness.  It says
you have to at least make an
effort.  On the right, you just
need to change your frame of
mind, then you'll feel better.
Have you tried, you know, not
having the flu? I don't think
it's healthy that you have to
take medication every day just
to feel normal.  Don't you worry
that it's
changing you from who you really
are? It's like you're not even
trying.  Lying in bed is not
helping you.  You need to try
something else.  And all of the
stigma and shame is a big
problem.  Even in high income
countries like Iceland and the
United States, anywhere from 35
to 50% of people with mental
disorders do not receive any
kind of treatment.  And that's a
problem, because, for example,
with severe depression, 50% of
people end up dying by suicide.
So when the stakes are so high,
you would think that people
would speak up.  The reason they
don't is because of fear.  Fear
of dismissal, fear of being
taken out of promotion
consideration, fear of reduced
hours for hourly workers.  Fear
of being asked to take unpaid
medical leave, and just in
general, a fear of being treated
differently.  And another
problem in the workplace and
especially in western countries
is you have this idea that you
should leave your personal life
at home when you come to work.
But with mental illness, you
can't just shut off your
depression for eight hours a
day, work productively, and come
home and deal with your
depression again.  We have to do
a better job of accepting people
as their whole selves.
Now I'll talk a
little about myself and why I
speak up about this.  And I
legitimately get asked this
question a lot, because I am
software a engineer just like
all of you.  I'm not a mental
health professional.  I have
taken one psychology class in my
whole life.  I also identify as
mentally healthy.
There are others who speak up
about this topic and they
usually do so because they are
living with mental illness
themselves.  The reason why
I speak up is because of her.
She is my best friend.  We met
while we New York  were both
living inCity.  She had just
moved there from Seattle.  She
studied biochem in college.  She
was interested in design and
technology, and she convinced a
company to give her a fellowship
where she could learn the tools
of the job on the job.  So she
and I hit it off immediately and
became really close, and she was
doing really well at work.  And
studied biochem in college.  She
was interested in design and
technology, and she convinced a
company to give her a fellowship
where she could learn the tools
of the job on the  after about a
year and a half in New York
City, she realized that the next
best thing that she could do to
ed a  advance her career is move
to San Francisco and work at a
start-up.  I was sad to see her
go, but we kept in touch and
still talked all the time.  When
she got to San Francisco, her
imposter syndrome started
becoming more of a problem,
coming from a non-traditional
background in tech.  That was an
issue, because she had been
living most of her adult life
with bipolar disorder.  We
thought she was doing okay.  We
thought she was doing better, so
it took us all by surprise when
in September 2016, she took her
own life.  So all of this is
still really difficult for me to
talk about.
If you want to know more about
this, I wrote
a very long blog post about this
on medium last year.  But after
all of this happened, and after
I had a little bit of time to
process all of this, I realized
that I
wanted to turn my grief into
action.  I started volunteering
with an organization called open
sourcing mental illness.  He had
been part of the PHP conference
circuit for a number of years.
About four or five years ago, he
started speaking up about his
own experiences.  His talk
resonated with a lot of penal,
and they decided to form a whole
organization around it, which is
an official nonprofit in the
United States now called
And so  open sourcing mental
illness or OSMI.awareness
campaigns are a really big part
of what OMSI does.  But we also
have a research arm.  We put out
a survey every year where we
basically ask any and all of you
working in the tech industry to
answer these questions that
allow us to gauge what the
attitudes are towards mental
health in tech.  Every year we
will change up the questions a
little bit.  But there's always
a variation of this one
question, which shows us we have
a lot of work to do.  It's two
variations of one question.  Do
you think discussing a physical
health issue with your employer
would have negative
consequences? And do you think
discussing a mental health issue
with your employer would have
negative consequences.  On the
left, for the physical health
question, the noes make up 75%
of all the responses.  But on
the right for the mental health
questions, the yeses and maybes
make up two-thirds of the pie.
That's a pretty striking
difference and shows that we
have a lot of work to do.
So I've
been involved for almost a year
and a half now, and my biggest
contribution in this community
has been to sit back and listen
to people like Ed tell their
stories and try to think about
what people like me can do.
There have been times when that
has been tough.  But there's a
quote that Ed used in one of his
talks that I thought was really
powerful and it opened my eyes
to how I really needed to
approach this.  I can do so many
awesome things if only my own
head didn't get in the way.  The
first time I heard this, it
stopped me in my tracks.  My
ability to do my job as a
software engineer rests solely
in my head.  I don't need
muscles.  I'm not a construction
worker.  I go to work every day
and take for granted that my
brain is going to do everything
I tell it to do.  But people
like Ed can't do that.  So I
started thinking about, you
know, what if this is how I felt
as I went about my day? How
would my environment have to
change in order to accommodate
this better? And so that kind of
led me down this path of
thinking more about what can the
rest of
us do? I started characterizing
the tech industry and think
about what the unique challenges
andistics character
are.  Many of us have relocated
for a job.  Most of us work
remotely at least part of the
time.  So
many specific things break
overnight, and there is a heavy
emphasis on drinking culture.
So I started thinking about this
in
particular.  My friend, Ni, had
relocated twice.
One of
her friends mentioned at the
funeral that she mentioned she
kind of regretted not going back
to Seattle where her family was.
I was thinking about this a lot
and thinking it can't be all
bad.  There have to be
legitimate reasons why we
relocate.  So I started
approaching it from that angle,
thinking about what are the
pros and cons.  On the  positive
side, it makes it easier to feel
like you're part of the team and
helping towards the mission if
you're on site with everyone
else.  It can bring you closer
to a community of practitioners
in your field compared to where
you currently are.  It takes
someone away from the existing
support structures that they
have already Beaumont up, like
the therapist they are seeing or
the friend you can go to see at
1:00 in the morning because you
need a good cry.  Moving is
generally stressful, and making
new friends as an adult is
surprisingly hard.  I started
thinking about solutions, and I
promise
I'm going to focus more on
pragmatic ones, but the first
one is a bit more aspirational.
But I strongly believe that as a
community we need to stop saying
the best way to succeed in tech
is to
relocate to silicon valley.  We
need to be a lot more accepting
of alternative choices.  If you
are a manager, take another look
at hiring practices and see
whether hiring remote first
employees is an option.  And
finally, if that's not an
option, if someone does have to
relocate to join your company,
be sure you focus on helping
introduce that colleague to
people in the area after hours,
ways for them to start building
up the support structures again.
I mentioned remote work as a
positive, and I think in
general, it is a positive.  For
example, it often leads to more
flexible hours, and that in turn
is good, because it makes it
easier to attend daytime therapy
appoints.  It turns out that
therapists like to work 9 to 5
Monday through Friday like all
the rest of us.  So a lot of
people that I've
talked to have said that working
from home on the day that you
see your therapist is so much
easier because you can duck out
without everyone knowing that
you're
going somewhere else.  It's
often easier to take medication
and breaks and it's easier than
being in the office.
But there is a sense of
isolation.  I have a couple of
friends who have started working
from home.  Why have I not been
doing this my entire life.  I
love working in my pajamas, this
is great.  But after two
months, a sense of isolation
sets in, and they start
complaining about feeling
lonely.
They miss the water cooler
conversations and connections
with colleagues.
And along the same lines, in
general, working can remotely
make it harder to build strong
relationships with your
co-workers, especially if you're
the only one who is remote.  If
good you just want to be a
supportive colleague, it can
make it harder
to
it can also make it challenging
to maintain a work life balance,
especially tell if arch is doing
okay.  And
if you are truly working from
home and your home is your
office, I have heard people say
it's difficult to
say it's 5:00, I'm not going to
respond to work e-mails and
Slack anymore.
Some solutions? Co-working
spaces are excellent and
undervalued.  And I think one of
the biggest barriers to people
trying it out is there is often
initiation fee or a monthly fee
that you have to pay.  So a good
solution for this is to have the
company at
the very least pay for the first
month so the person will be more
likely to try it and see if this
is for them.  This not something
that you is have to do every
day.
I have heard even if people go
into a co-working space once a
week, it's helpful and makes
them feel less
isolated.  Make sure you
occasionally fly in remote
employees or hold offsite
meetings to make sure everyone
feels a part of the team and
they're getting a chance to
bond.  And there's
research around remote work
culture and how to make it
better.  There's so many
resources to leverage.  There
are conferences around this now.
Look at the latest state of the
art around remote work.  Try
some things with you team if you
find that you are still
struggling and see if it works
Therefor you.  are just so many
things to try.
So, the first time that I was
going give this talk, one of the
things that surprised
me the most was someone came
back and said what about open
plan offices? What are you
planning to say about that? I
actually had not planned on
saying anything at all, but I
figured it's a good khi.
Question.  I will do research.
Creative problem solving between
multiple employees, people
having more organic
conversations that led to
solutions.  I used to think
that's why everyone did it, but
it's actually easier to
construct offices that way
because of things like building
fire codes.  It can also
increase a sense of team unity,
but I really want to emphasize
the can here.  If there's
already friction, it can
increase resentment instead.  On
the negative side, the number
one complaint is the noise and
how it reduces productivity.
From a mental health
perspective, I think the biggest
concern is the lack of privacy.
When I talked about remote work
before, working from home makes
it easier to duck out in the
afternoon for your therapy
appointment, this is the exact
opposite.  You're working
closely with everyone, so if you
need to duck out for a therapy
appointment, everyone's going to
know about it.  People have
cited an increased sense of
stress, and there's increased
peer pressure.  And this is a
problem for mental health,
because I think it's -- it
happens quite often to us as
developers where sometimes we
just get stuck.  And we realize
that the absolute best thing
that we can do for ourselves is
to take a break for 20 minutes,
take a walk around the block, do
something completely different.
What often happens is you look
around and everyone else is bent
over their desks and they look
productive.  What happens in
that case is you talk yourself
out of taking that break.  And
that's actually the worst
possible thing that you can do
for yourself in that moment.
And finally, open plan
offices are also highly
conducive to the spread of
physical disease like the cold,
the flu, etc.
So, again, I'm focusing on
pragmatic solutions.  I would
love to come up here and say we
should not have open plan
offices, but I think the vast
majority of us are not in a
position to make that call.  So
the next easiest and best thing
to do is to make sure that
everyone is allowed to work
remotely.  Or if they are
already, maybe increase the
number of days per week or month
when they can do so.
Regardless, always encourage
your employees to work from home
when they're sick.  Maybe try
setting aside SMAM  small myth
spaces for quiet work.  I think
for those of us with big
offices, one thing that happens
is there's that one conference
room that's too small to have a
productive meeting in.  Maybe
set that one aside for people to
check out for like an hour if
they realize they need a bit of
quiet time in the afternoon
where they can get some
productive work done.
Also, have the company provide
noise cancelling headphones.
This is often the easiest
solution, and it does work
pretty effectively.  And
encourage employees to decorate
their work space.  It may sound
like they have nothing to do
with improving offices and
productivity at all, but
research actually says the
opposite.  There was a 2014
study in Sweden where they
tested different office
configurations and they had the
people who worked in them rate
how those conditions made them
feel.  The one that was rated
the worst among men was the open
plan flex office.  It's an open
plan office where no one has
their own desk.  There was a
2010 study done in the UK where
they compared people who had
decorated and personalized their
work spaces, and those who
decorated were a third more
productive.  As silly as it
sounds, these hacks work.
And now alcohol at tech
events.  One or two drinks can
make it easier for some
introverts and those with social
anxiety to socialize with their
peers.  I'm guilty of that as
well.  If you don't offer
alcohol, then those who want to
drink will go to a bar instead
of staying to mingle.  So
conferences like this one,
that's often the reason they
have alcohol.  They want
everyone to stay and socialize
and network.  That's the whole
point of having conferences like
this.
But on the negative side, it
makes non-drinkers feel
unwelcome in general.  And if
you're a recovering alcoholic,
then you're definitely going to
feel threatened at a kind of
event where alcohol is flowing
freely.  Alcoholism
is a mental health disorder.
There are probably more high
functioning alcoholics in tech
than we are aware of.  Some of
the solutions, I personally am
not saying no one should have
alcohol at tech events again.  I
think there are steps to try in
the meantime.  One thing that
some places have tried are, for
example, making sure that you
always offer nice alternatives.
The fancy sodas that come in the
glass bottles or mocktails to
make sure that non-drinkers feel
included.  Often the biggest
insult to them is to get to the
afterparty and everyone else is
getting customized cocktails and
they get lukewarm sodas where
they have to fill their own ice.
Make sure that you're treating
everyone equally.  Put a limit
on the number of free drinks
that you give out.  Use a ticket
or token system.  People usually
do this for budget reasons, but
it works out well for health
reasons as well.  You will get
two drink tickets, and after
that it turns into a cash bar.
What that leads to is someone
will have their two free drinks
and they will think, do I want
to take out my wallet to have
the third drink? And then they
will realize I have a good buzz
going, and maybe I don't need
the third drink, and then
they're not getting drunk and
you don't have to deal with
those health consequences.
Always, always make sure that
you have activities other than
drinking.  There's a pretty big
overlap between developers and
people who like playing board
games.  You would think that
more tech events would have
things like a board game night.
If you're having a recurring
series of events like a monthly
meet-up, try alternating dry and
non-dry events.  You don't have
to drink every single time.  And
add workplace wellness programs
on substance abuse.  These are
the kind of things where most of
them would roll our eyes at them
when it happens.  Most of us
need that periodic reminder that
there are serious consequences
to drinking too much.  And that
reinforcement is just very
helpful.
For managers and tech leads
and senior devs, overall the
biggest piece of advice is to
lead by example.  Things like
not micromanaging, leaving the
office on time, taking regular
vacations yourself, not sending
or answering e-mails at 2:00
a.m., being receptive to
feedback, and being a good
listener.  And really the only
thing that I would say that is
unique to mental health is that
you should try to be more open
to talking about your own mental
health or maybe something that
happened in your family.  It
turns out that really, your
number one goal should be, for
your employees or your reports
to come to you and say look, I'm
struggling with this issue.  I
might need an accommodation.
That sort of thing.  But people
are not going do that if you
haven't been more vulnerable and
open about things that you
yourself have struggled with.
It sounds counter intuitive.  I
feel like by the time we get to
the senior level, we should be
completely invincible, but
actually being vulnerable is
probably one of your best asset
assets.
Some other action items for
managers? Make sure your
employees understand benefits
and what mental health
treatments are covered.  Revisit
diversity.  And I will talk more
about neurodiversity in a
minute.  Make sure your
employees feel valued and
empowered.  This may sound like
it has nothing to do with mental
health, but this is the single
biggest take-away for me is that
I've noticed a trend.  When
people are saying I feel like my
depression is starting to come
back.  I feel like my symptoms
are getting worse, it's often
accompanied by a change at work.
They got put on a different
project.  They feel like they're
not getting as many changes to
give feedback or make changes in
the process.  Management is not
being transparent about why
they're doing this, etc., etc.
So making sure people feel
valued and are feeling fulfilled
is really important for mental
wellness as well.
Get the OSMI
handbooks.  Two of them deal
with the Americans with
disabilities act.  They're
probably only relevant if you're
in the U.S., but the third talks
about starting a mental wellness
program in the workplace.  And
finally, consider offering the
mental health first aid
training.  Mental health first
aid is an international program
started in Australia, and is
available in all of these
countries in Europe, the U.S.,
and Canada, and I believe in
India and Nepal as well.  It's
either eight or 12 hours, and
the whole focus is to teach you
how to respond if you encounter
somebody having a mental health
crisis.  I have heard from many
people that they found it useful
as a sort of empathy training as
well.  So if you're trying to
find the most effective way to
really truly get everyone to
respond to mental health better
in your company, this is
probably the best thing that you
can do.  And it can sometimes be
challenging to sometimes attend
a training.  They are often
limited in when and where
they're given.  If you're based
in Iceland, it's not even one of
the countries on the list.  But
you can bring in a train tore
give -- trainer to give the
training on site, which is a
great way to make sure that all
of your employees get trained or
everyone on the management team
gets trained, etc.
So finally, I'll spend a couple
of minutes talking about the
stuff that we all have do
together where everyone has to
do their part.  The first big
thing is making sure that we're
always supported marginalized
people in the tech industry.
Chronic harassesment, bullying,
and more can lead to depression
and cause or worsen other mental
illnesses.  People are often
surprised when I mention eating
disorders in the context of
tech.  Even in tech, women are
still judged by their
appearance.  In the silicon
valley start-up culture, I have
heard a lot of stories about
women being told that you only
got this interview because
you're pretty.  If you're
already suffering with issues of
body image and eating disorders,
this will just make it worse.
In general, people from
marginalized groups feel that
they have to overperform.  And
so that overperforming leads to
increased stress and the much
greater likelihood of burn-out.
We also need to fully
embrace neurodiversity.  It's
this idea that mental disorders
are the result of natural
variations of the human genome.
They say people with these
differences do not need to be
cured.  They need help and
accommodation instead.  The
strongest proponents say we
should stop looking for a cure
for autism all together.  I
think that's a little bit
controversial, and it's probably
worth it to keep looking for a
cure, but I also recognize that
even if we do find a cure, it's
probably only going to help the
people who aren't born yet.
Chances are it will not help
anyone who is living with autism
right now.  There are multiple
generations of people with
autism who deserve to live
healthy, happy, productive
lives.  Some of our greatest
inventions are attributed to
people with atypical neurology.
Ed has this quote, mental
illness gives me
superpowers.
He talks about how his ADHD
helps him in ways that others
hadn't thought of before.  There
was an article from last May
called neurodiversity as a
competitive advantage where they
found the same thing.  People
with autism working in companies
like IBM and HP were actually
incredibly productive, thinking
of solutions no one had thought
of, its.  And  the biggest
barrier was bringing them in.
They had to change up the
interview process for these
people to enter the companies.
Some things we can only
change as a culture, the idea of
working ourselves to death.  The
overemphasis on hard work and
stigma against things like
vacation.  And the idea that the
best programmers always code on
the holidays.  That kind of
idea.  The need to always be
available by phone or e-mail.  I
go to Iceland to speak at a
conference like this, and I feel
pressured to tell everyone how
to reach me in case of an
emergency, and that shouldn't be
the case.  The peer pressure
caused by social media.  A study
found that people suffering from
depression struggle a lot with
using Facebook, because everyone
posts about the good things that
happen in their lives.  So
seeing everyone else seemingly
happy with their weddings and
babies make them feel worse and
more down on yourselves.  I
mentioned this before, the
belief that you must be in
silicon valley to succeed.  The
stigma against talking about our
feelings, and finally the idea
that engineers don't have
empathy.  I went to art school,
so this is new for me.  I was
talking with a woman who started
her own business and she brought
in a consultant who said you can
never use the word empathy
around your engineers because
they all believe you don't have
it.  Empathy is something we all
have the capacity for.  We just
have to choose to exercise it.
There is a quote by the same
woman that I thought was really
powerful.  Empathy is the about
dote to shame.  She mentioned
this in the context of the shame
and blame culture of tech, but
true in mental illness as well.
Shame is the stigma, and so
empathy is the about dote.
Hopefully you figured out this
is in jest.  There is no app for
this.  We can't deploy it to the
cloud.  We can't automate it
away.  This is something we have
the capacity for, and we have to
choose to exercise it as a
service to imp.  If  you are
struggling, I bring you back to
the quote from Ed's talk.  I
could do so many things if only
my head didn't get in the way.
I have a list of resources in my
slides.  Feel free to ask me if
you want to know what any of
these are for.
Feel free to reach out at any
time.  If six months are from
now, you want to talk about
something, my proverbial door is
always open.
I do also have OSMI stickers, so
come talk to me if you want one
of those.  Thank you very
much.
[ Applause ]
>> That was amazing. I just
want to say, I relate to so much
of what you said.  I relocated
most of my life.  I think I
never lived or went to school
somewhere for more than five,
four years or something like
that? So, I'm always moving.  So
that's really real.  And the
stuff that you say about someone
saying to you that you only got
that job because you're pretty
has been said to me many
different variations, which is
not great.  Anyway.  I have a
lot of questions to ask you, but
we can take a lot of this
online.  But, one of it is how
can we openly discuss more
mental health in our workplaces?
It's really difficult to
actually get people to talk
about this stuff.  People are
always talking about performance
in the office or being more
productive, and how can we be
more efficient in this processes
that we do? But we never really
include mental health on top of
that.
>> That's true. I think one of
the things that I've noticed
that helps the most is if it
starts from the top.  If you're
a manager and you have dealt
with depression or anxiety
before, speak up about that,
because everyone else at the
bottom is more likely to speak
up if they see someone else
higher up in the organization
who is open about this.  This is
something that is consciously on
my mind as a senior developer
now.  I should not try to create
this image of myself as being
perfect.  I should draw
attention to the mistakes that I
make and the things I struggle
with, because that makes it
easier for everyone else to talk
about it.
>> Thank you so much. So we're
going to go for our break.
I think we have a 30, 40 minute
break, and we will come back
here around 2:50.  So yeah, I'll
see you
back here.